صحيح في الساعات الاخيره ومنذ ساعات الفجر
قوات الاحتلال تتعمد قصف مستشفى الشفاء
بعدد من القذائف هي ليست قذيفه واحده هي
ثلاث قذائف وبعد ورود الخبر الاول الى
غرفه الاخبار قصفت قوات الاحتلال مره اخرى
الطابق الثالث في مستشفى التخصصي نشاهد
اكثر عن قرب في هذا المشهد القصف
الاسرائيلي الذي وصل الى مستشفى الشفاء
بدايه كان القصف الاسرائيلي في الساحه مما
وقع شهيدين في هذا القصف الاول فيما بعد
قصفت قوات الاحتلال هذا الجسر ومحيطه ارضا
وهنا كانت اغلب البسطات والباعه الذين
يعملون على بيع المواطنون في داخل مستشفى
الشفاء وقع هناك قرابه 11 شهيدا في المره
الثالثه قصفت قوات الاحتلال من الجهه
الشرقيه لهذا المبنى قصفت قوات الاحتلال
بقذيفه اخرى هذا المبنى مما اث مما وقع
ثمانيه شهداء جل هؤلاء الاطفال جل هؤلاء
الشهداء من الاطفال وهذه المجزره التي
ارتكبها الاحتلال بحق ان النازحين وتعمد
بقصفهم حالنا في داخل مجمع الشفاء الان
حال صعب جدا في ظل عدم وجود اي من الكوادر
الطبيه التي تقوم باجراء العمليات
بالاضافه الى انقاذ حياه المرضى والمصابين
في داخل هذا المجمع الان الوضع في خطر بعد
اطلاق قوات الاحتلال الرصاص المتكرر
والقذائف الصاروخيه المتكرره على هذا
المجمع ثلاث مرات قصفت قوات الاحتلال مجمع
الشفاء الطبي مما اثار حاله من الرعب
وحاله من القلق داخل هذا المجمع الكثير لا
يعرف مصيره حالنا كحال النازحين في داخل
هذا المجمع ننتظر الساعات القادمه لنرى ما
ان كانت قوات الاحتلال سترتكب مجازر اكبر
في داخل هذا المجمع قصف الشرق وقصف الغرب
والجنوب والشمال والان بقي النازحون داخل
مجمع الشفاء الطبي لا يعرفون اين يذهبون
او اين يتوجهون بعد القصف المتواصل حتى
وصل الى اماكن نزوحهم طيب الان هذا
الاستهداف كما ذكرت اسماعيل لمستشفى
الشفاء وهي تضم الان في هذه اللحظات بين
جنباتها عدد كبير جدا جدا من النازحين
الذين لجوا الى المستشفى عقب كل
الاستهدافات التي تقع في شمال قطاع
غزه صحيح الكثير من هؤلاء النازحين هم من
المناطق الشماليه لقطاع غزه بالاضافه الى
المناطق الشرقيه تجمعوا وتكدس داخل هذه
البنايات علما ان البنايات تحتوي على
عشرات الاف من النازحين اي قذيفه صاروخيه
توقع عشرات الشهداء وعشرات الاصابات
بالاضافه الى ذلك قسم الطوارئ هو قسم
يحتوي على عدد بسيط من الاطباء بالاضافه
الى الممرضين والمتطوعين كثير من العائلات
داوت جروحها بنفسها وكثيرا من الشهداء
وقعوا وسقطوا شهداء بسبب عدم وجود كوادر
طبيه لتنقذ حياتهم ا علما ان هذا المشفى
وهذا المكان او الجهه الغربيه لمدينه غزه
هي المكان الوحيد الان الذي يتجمع به
عشرات الالاف من النازحين وتواصل قوات
الاحتلال قصف هذه المباني والتعمد في قصف
المستشفيات وشاهدنا فيما قبل ان هذا هذه
الم مباني قصفت بالاضافه ان هذه الساحات
احتلت من قوات الاحتلال تحديدا مبنى
الجراحات التخصصيه الذي استهدف الان وكما
ذكرنا هناك انباء عن سقوط شهداء حدثنا عن
ما الذي يحتويه هذا
المبنى صحيح هذا المبنى قد نعيد تركيز
الصوره اكثر هذا المبنى يحتوي اذا لاحظنا
على النوافذ هذا المكان يحتوي على عائلات
النازحين الذين نزحوا من المناطق الشرقيه
والشماليه تاوي هذه المباني العائلات لا
مفار امام هذه العائلات في كل غرفه اكثر
من عائله في كل ممر تحتوي ايضا عائلات هذا
الجسر الذي نسلط الكاميرا عليه تبي فيه
العائلات بعد عدم توفر مساحات كافيه في
الغرف التي تحتوي على العائلات وامتلاء
الممرات بقي هذا الممر وهذه الساحه هي
الوحيده التي تاوي النازحين بالاضافه الى
اسفل هذا الجسر هو السوق الذي يعني يعتبر
سوق مستشفى الشفاء في هذه اللحظات يعني و
بناء على ذلك قصف هذا المكان الذي يحتوي
على النازحين صورنا عن قرب هذا المكان
وراينا ان اغلب الشهداء هم اطفال ونساء
وكثير من هذه العائلات مصابه وكان كثير من
المتواجدين داخل المبنى لا يوجد من ينقذهم
او يجليه بسبب حتى توفر كوادر طبيه كافيه
الجميع قد يرى اسفل هذا المبنى العائلات
تنتقل من مبنى الى اخر ركض على او سيرا
بسرعه وركض انتقالا وتخوف من قوات
الاحتلال التي تتواجد في نهايه هذا الشارع
المطل الى مستشفى الشفاء في نهايه هذا
الشارع هو مفترق ضبض الذي تتواجد عليه
دبابات الاحتلال يعرف هذا المكان انه مجمع
الشفاء الطبي لان هذه القوات احتلت هذا
المجمع من قبل لكن يبدو ان قوات الاحتلال
تقصف هذا المجمع بشكل متعمد نحن ننقل
الصوره من داخل الخطر ومن بين النازحين
مصيرنا كمصير الجميع هنا ننتظر اذا كان
قوات الاحتلال سترتكب مجازر ج
في هذا اليوم قسف مجمع الشفاء ثلاث مرات
ولا نعرف مصير الساعات القادمه حماكم الله
ونشكرك حتى اللحظه من مستشفى الشفاء
بمدينه غزه مراسل الجزيره اسماعيل الغول